John Wick chapter four John Wick
represents a sort of an innate goodness
even though he's killed half a million
people after three films that got bigger
and bigger what else are they gonna do
new characters more World building
and going to die
maybe not this mad genius has created
some really wonderful extraordinary
sequences
I know that he's well trained you know
trains a lot and he have all these
experience and I know that I'm in safe
hands
my training process had that extra added
pressure of like yo Shamir don't mess
this up right because you're rocking
with hero
you know Keanu Reeves three two one
action
I don't think I've ever worked on a
production before where I've been in
these opulents over-the-top exclusive
locations welcome to one of my mini
offices
you come here thinking there is a way
out of this world for you Mr Wick
there is not
I was doing Jiu Jitsu Muay Thai Judo
weapon training and I think the one
thing that I had the one up on everybody
else that got to train with the dog
and that dog was uh you know a cuddly
cuddly beautiful thing that was great
but became a grizzly bear if it needed
to
I've done everything but oh come on
everything okay
come on this is hero he does everything
he even does much stunts because I can't
even do it you know I want you to find
your peace but the good death
only comes after a good life
[Music]
you and I left a good life behind a long
time ago my friend just as a fan
watching it it's a it's a visceral
loving it it's a visceral like wanting
more you know wanted Johnny to kick more
butt
you know when we riff about ideas and we
you know if he offers something and you
know like I think we're gonna do this
with the cars in chapter four
[Music]
he's like yeah what if that character
did that and then we just start cooking
it up fun process to make the movie that
you wanted to see in the first place so
last words Winston just have fun out
there I don't know I I think it's I'm
I'm look you're excited about look you
got
off who is this
challenge him to single combat win a
lose it's a way out the high table is
you know a little angry John Wick's a
little angry trying to survive I don't
sit at the table your family does
I was a huge fan of the franchise I
think they're really fun if you win
the table will honor its word
we will have your freedom
but you want tickets
he's sort of the new sheriff in town
he's appointed at a high position to a
surprise surprise track down and kill
John Wick Bill Skarsgard he really went
for it a new day is Dawning
new ideas no rules
New Management you make it look easy
either it's wild it's my first movie and
and it's my first action with a lot of
stunts we just had the London premiere
and I've never been so nervous in my
whole life I was shaking saying goodbyes
saying hello
you think your wife can hear you
no
a white ball
Maybe I'm Wrong
you know I believe in fate Destiny right
I read the first draft originally given
to me and I was convinced that I said
all right you know I'll do it so got on
a plane and I went to Germany
he's human right he's complex he's cool
you're going to die
maybe not I think they want to create an
equal to John a new franchise they
introduced a new character you got to
have a certain substance there at the
same time they're different but they
understand each other so there's a
connection there yeah I think it'll work
out fine because of John Wick's actions
my dad's been killed and I have taken
the mantle and I'm now kind of the queen
of the Romas he's coming over because he
needs to get a Crest from the family to
be invited back into the family Clan so
we can um support his uh challenge the
Marquee as you build out the John Wick
University how do you pull that world
together I guess we just try to have fun
there hasn't been one we haven't done we
haven't had a blast around
usually over some Scotch but yeah
well hey I'm a sec I mean maybe at the
end of the meeting where there was a
couple where you know go to the Muse a
glass of scotch and just kind of dream
dream
week and welcome
to low resistance I've come up with my
own theory if it's people are like well
it's revenge and there's the rules and
there's the World building and it's so
cool and it's all those things but for
me it comes down to one thing which is
John Wick is a guy who wants to be free
to be himself and everybody wants to be
free the latest and Ballistic Chic
appropriate for all formal occasions
weddings funerals high table duels
after all man has to look his best when
it's time to get married
or buried these Keanu Reeves
like I grew up with the Matrix franchise
and put a big fan of his ever since I
was a kid and he really cares
I think one of the things
he feel the love from you too
when you bow down to them at Brazil
Comic-Con there's a lot of people who um
who want to kill John Wick and uh that's
their first mistake so I know so I've
been silly gosh looked at selfish right
I'm getting to do what I love he's still
an audience member like he loves Cinema
you want to get him excited talk movies
he's on set and you can't get him all
upset like he's there like he doesn't
want to miss a minute of filmmaking
here but it's not only the place that's
special it's all the people and everyone
ultimately what are we doing there we're
telling stories because you I'm not here
within out an audience right absolutely
and I don't complete the circle of being
in the storytelling frame without an
audience
what about you Mr Vic
I'm going to kill you a gazillion people
are going to see it and a gazillion
people are going to keep singing he
represents something that's good pure
about what he feels about his wife he
feels about the dog he feels about
loyalty and I think it sort of resonates
in some strange kind of way through all
the Mayhem and everything else that he's
a good guy how goes the ground farewell
tour
coming to an end
so it seems so it seems I love that
experience of going to the cinema and
sharing a story a film with other people
and there's just nothing like it
I play John Wick in this film being
directed by Len Wiseman called ballerina
to take this into like the next chapter
she's got that little bit of of
reevesism like she has an honesty tour
there's true
um inspiration in it like she loves
movies well first of all she's a
wonderful actor and second of all you've
already seen her action shops in James
Bond
and I was excited to do it and it was
like I love that painting but I'm gonna
go make that my own and so it was cool
to like be in someone else's painting
you forget that the Russ garoma is bound
by the high table and the height table
stands above all she seemed to really
not only like the character like the
property of John Wick but she had her
take on it and she took something very
different away from it and I think for
what Lynn Wiseman is trying to do about
Arena I think you needed a fresh
perspective and I couldn't be more happy
if they took it in a direction that we
haven't thought of or maybe we we
haven't explored yet
I thought we play a game
one hand
s who lives
it does not
buckle up you're gonna see some action
it's gonna be funny there's gonna be
some ideas you know rules consequences
surviving getting knocked down get back
up fight for your freedom go against the
man
foreign